what up gq i'm face temper i'm face
kayleigh face of dad face swag and we're
face clan today we're going undercover
on the internet
it's actually us
[Music]
reddit let's go
how would you rank the cod games from
worst to best top five cod top five top
five all right one for two for me one
more for three it's really close between
that's crazy mw2 bo2 mw3 i'm not an
order cod 4 you gotta add in there
you're bugging yeah what yo
cod what you're getting the most right
now black ops 3 is better than cod 4.
you're swag
what black ops 3 is gold who just pissed
off the entire cody
we need to get out of this question
right now okay all right listen top five
cards in no random order model for two
black ops two call of duty four modifier
three and
you know black ops three okay i can
respect it next
keyboard and mouse or controller on pc
and wondering which is the most
advantage in warzone i mean when it
comes to keyboard and mouse keyboard is
more transferable to like valerian apex
any other game but when it comes to
warzone definitely controller because
it's aim assist
next
all right jonesy bonesy man i don't ask
for much in life but can faze please
bring back illcam for 2022. that's just
impossible like the game's not the same
if we're in like a modern warfare 2 era
then yeah it's possible
they are they're remaking it i'll
believe it when i see it but it's gonna
be hard to kind of recreate what we did
with ill cams back on the old cars with
the new cars if you watch those ill cams
you kind of understand so some things
are you just can't recreate recreate
right never was the same and like look
how many hangover movies they made
can temper still do the temper shot oh
of course
not a full 360.
never that
replied
youtube
to the home
[Music]
this is the phase clan i miss good old
days so i see a lot of comments like
that people are always so afraid to see
things grow and change and become better
we would have never got here right
yeah here that would have never happened
like you need to be able to grow and
change next
[Music]
is brony actually good at gaming bro
bronie's actually a barney's a beast
he's a demon in the games he was a nut
yes he plays on mountain keyboard and
controller that's crazy he does play
mouse and key yeah that's
crazy he's special
[Music]
so when do we get a nike phase collab
i'm waiting hey
imagine yeah air jordan once
it's not out of the question wait on it
twitter twitter
did faceclan create the first content
house yeah we did
i remember being in the skype call over
the summer in like 2014 when we all
thought let's get a house together now
it's like a normal thing a content house
and having people move in when i used to
watch back in the day i just started
getting to call of duty when they were
in the face house and i remember seeing
you guys and it was just so cool that me
and my boys would try to almost mimic
that like we would i would have them
come over you know what i'm saying like
you guys make gaming together like in
that crib so cool
who do you think hit the best trick
shots while living in the house
oh for sure
no it's just not true whoever voted here
i swear
they weren't tapped in did you bro i'm
talking to 1080
fade shot predator missile cancel wall
bang
the shot off the crane alone is just
that's going to do it for me some are
saying that's a one hit
snoop sign with the big dogs yes
his face he's officially part of the
team i don't know if y'all saw for the
halftime show yeah he was wearing the
face clan chain you're going to see a
lot more of him and us shout out to face
snoop
face dog let's go gora what is korra i
don't know what is cool i've never been
on
how do you join phase we are having a
recruitment challenge and that's phase
one right now anybody can apply
hopefully you make into the top 100 top
20 maybe be the phase one next
how does faze clan make money um
you do cool [ __ ] on the internet
that's it
pc gaming versus console gaming what are
the advantages of each platform over the
other and which is better so pc is the
fov you have better frames the overall
quality of life on the game is just
better in general the advantages i say
to console or for a lot of smaller
creators you can stream directly from
the consoles now which is really dope
yeah so anybody who's starting out
doesn't need a three thousand dollar pc
like they can just buy a console and get
right to content corrections which is
better i think pc yeah i mean for sure
pc all day replied
how are twitch streamers so good at
video games they gotta be cheating well
i mean when you invest 10 hours a day
into a video game i hope you're good oh
yeah how many hours a day do you guys
stream i'm streaming 12 to 15 hours a
day
yeah i'm not doing 12 to 15. i usually
do like seven but i do a lot of
consecration outside of that yeah it's
constant next
wikipedia
originally faze clan did not have a
corporate structure however the original
ceo was brazilian thomas temper oliveira
who had been a member of faith since he
was 16 years old that's really how it
happened like we were
kids creating this what i thought was
like a team but i didn't realize like we
were creating a brand and a company it
became something much bigger than we
could have ever imagined it to be
ig ig
where can i buy a chain like that uh you
got to be a part of the family like
you can't buy this or you go to your
local jewelry oh yeah